bonsoir didier sapy merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france alors pas
de confinement à peut-être des mesures
ponctuelles d'isolement dans les ehpad
si la situation venait à se détériorer
selon le ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand est ce que vous êtes d'accord
justement avec le ministre de la santé
oui totalement d'accord totalement
d'accord il faut pas aujourd'hui
envisager de mesures globales pour
l'ensemble des établissements et pour
les quelque six cent mille personnes qui
y vivent
ce serait totalement injuste ce serait
très difficile à vivre pour elle après
non plus une période de forte chaleur
donc ce serait totalement inacceptable
par rapport à l'ensemble de la
population s'il devait y avoir un
confinement les deux pays pourraient
être nationale aujourd'hui c'est
totalement écarté il ya aucune raison
que ce soit le cas en établissement en
revanche effectivement le ministre a
raison sur sur la grande vigilance qu'il
faut dans nos établissements et sur la
gestion au cas par cas des situations
des situations de chaque structure est
ce que concrètement aujourd'hui les
ehpad de france sont presque y deuxième
vague il devait y avoir
oui je pense qu'ils sont présents ils
sont fatigués ils ont été très fatigué
par par la première vague
ils ont été usés ils ont eu en plus la
période estivale qui a pas été qui a pas
été facile en est en sous-effectif la
plupart du temps c'est très difficile et
ça reste très difficile
ils sont prêts parce qu'ils sont mieux
préparés aussi ils ont affronté la
première raison d'un certain nombre de
protocoles qui ont été mises en place on
a des équipements on est équipé en est
on est prêt à affronter la chose le plus
difficile je pense le plus inquiétant
c'est l'aspect humain les ressources
humaines qui pourraient venir à manquer
qui reste insuffisante dans les
établissements et sur lesquels on a
besoin mais là le le gouvernement
également nous apporte un certain un
certain soutien pour que y ait des
ressources humaines qu'ils soient mises
à disposition en cas de reprise de
l'épidémie dans certains établissements
le ministre a parlé d'eux
bur ponctuelles d'isolement ça veut dire
que ce serait plutôt du cas par cas
c'est ça c'est ça c'est du cas par cas à
l'échelle d'un établissement si vous
voulez un lorsque on a un cas de que
vides avérée dans un établissement
il faut bien entendu immédiatement testé
à peu près tout le monde et lorsqu'il ya
des résidents qui sont touchés il faut
mettre en oeuvre immédiatement les
mesures sanitaires qui s'impose en lien
avec les hôpitaux avec les ars avec les
autorités sanitaires
les équipes mobiles peuvent intervenir
dans l'établissement mettre en place les
protocoles qu'il faut pour protéger
bien entendu les autres résidents le
plus possible le le dilemme permanent
qu'on aux établissements c'est c'est ce
dilemme entre protéger la santé des
personnes la vie des personnes dont il
s'occupait de l'autre côté un
accompagnement le plus le plus humain
possible de comme c'est leur vocation à
la base leur métier c'est sain et cette
période que vidal est très perturbant
père très perturbantes pardon de ce
point de vue là parce qu'ils ont
l'impression de ne pas faire leur métier
habituel leur métier normal qui est
d'accompagner la vie et la qualité de
vie des personnes hélas les mesures de
protection elles sont elles sont souvent
souvent très forte mais c'est nécessaire
à l'échelle d'un établissement
lorsqu il y à des cas avérés il faut
vraiment organiser les choses à
l'intérieur de l'établissement
ça a déjà été fait dans la première
période il ya des zones que vides qui
peuvent être mises en place
on isole les personnes on teste tout le
monde
tous ces protocoles à son sont rodés
aujourd'hui vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que les ehpad et était prêt un que le
personnel aussi l'était en cas de
deuxième vague
grâce à son expérience de la première
est ce que les pensionnaires le sont
aussi et comment on peut éventuellement
les préparer mais je pense qu'ils ont
tout à fait conscience de la situation
dans la plupart des établissements ils
ont ils ont d'abord ils ont vécu le
confinement ils ont bien compris ce qui
se passait beaucoup l'ont l'eau d'autant
plus compris qu'ils l'ont acceptée même
vanité humaine c'est à dire qu' il était
reconnaissant envers les établissements
de les protéger justement de ce virus
qui attaque et fortement les personnes
très âgées puisque je vous rappelle que
91% des victimes de ce virus se sont
sont des personnes âgées
donc sachant qu'elles sont
particulièrement visés et la cible de ce
virus elle était reconnaissante et elles
sont reconnaissantes
elles sont prêtes l'a également
lorsqu'elles se sentent menacés par par
ce virus je pense qu'elles sont prêtes
aussi à accepter un certain nombre de
mesures
la plus difficile c'est bien sûr
isolement par rapport par rapport aux
familles et la de ce point de vue là on
en appel systématiquement à la
responsabilité aussi les familles on
sait que ce virus il va se transmettre
dans l'est dans les semaines qui
viennent par les jeunes vers les plus
les plus âgées puisque j'en ai vu que la
flambée du virus
aujourd'hui elle touche les 25-35 ans
essentiellement les 20 35 ans et donc il
faut absolument faire en sorte que ces
personnes lorsqu'elles sont porteuses et
qu'elles seront peut-être moins
gravement atteinte par la maladie ne
puisse pas le transmettre à des
personnes plus fragiles plus âgées qui
aiment pour lesquelles ça pourrait être
ça pourrait être dramatique
donc il faut vraiment que tout le monde
se comporte en responsabilité par
rapport à ça et accepte un certain
nombre de mesures de protection tout en
restant évidemment il faut garder cette
citoyenneté cette vie quotidienne le
plus possible et ce lien avec les
familles quelquefois autrement que autre
autre que physique lorsque c'est
possible bien sûr
voilà merci à didier
et ça pis on retiendra bien sûr la
vigilance à un partout et puis y compris
et surtout dans les ehpad merci d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de la fédération nationale
avenir et qualité de vie des des
personnes âgées merci beaucoup